Oh, we made it down to Chatham.
Oh, I hope we get a bite.
Staying positive.
You see, the whales,
the tuna are generally with them.
We started to hear them.
We set up, basically down sea of them.
Tons of bait here that they're feeding on.
Hopefully the tuna come through this.
Just deployed our first two baits.
We'll see what happens.
We won this thing last year
by coming down to Chatham
all the time,
but also by working with the hot tuna.
So we're going to continue with that
as long as possible
Did you find the whales Bob?
yeah, we know they're upwind of us.
We can hear them. Okay.
We're right close to Bobby's.
Just right up the line
a little bit from us here.
Chris crying like a baby's here.
I can't get them walk or a bite.
And me and Bob Cook on the fat tuna.
Stay in contact on the radio.
More efficient Chatham.
Anyone that's willing to steam down here
and put in the time
and the effort deserves
to be given the right information.
I thought we'd be headed home by now.
Of course we all did.
I heard a rumor that the hard merchant
fishing at Chatham, which to me is odd.
You know, he's
the one who's been hating on Chatham.
He says he's going to stay local
in Gloucester.
I think it might be BS,
but it's too early in the season
to stress about the other boats.
Usually when we're cooking, we hook up.
So hopefully it brings us a little luck
here.
I’d love to bend the rod
and get in early enough
so we can get back out here tomorrow
and do it again.
Ah, there he is.
We got a bouncer.
Hopefully we get a nice one.
I haven’t heard the
whales here for a little bit now.
They definitely moved on.
Can we smell them?
Oh
We just got bit.
We’re on!
We're on.
150 seems real.
Seems real. Bob's got them on. How deep?
150. That's
got to be right in front of his face.
Whoo, we're on.
Good one good one.
And this is why we come down here.
Get it, buddy.
You know, they can say what they want.
Let us burn the fuel we want.
But this is where the fish at.
Whoa.
What is that?
You got it?
Yeah. Thanks, buddy.
Yeah.
You know, full bellies
always keeps the crew happy.
So when you're in a good mood,
you usually hook fish.
There he is.
Got him on baby!
Whoo!
Saw the rod bouncing around tight,
you know, fingers crossed.
It turns into a tuna.
It's hoping it's not a shark.
Be honest.
Well it’s swimming
up awful fast.
I feel like it might be a tuna personally.
Only because a shark.
I feel it would
come up a lot faster by now.
Oh, see?
That's them, right?
Just took some line right off
the reel that time.
You never know. Definitely a tuna.
I'm not sold this is a fish.
Fingers crossed.
We can land this thing
and head for the barn.
Ready, Johnny?
Yeah. Straight in like a tuna.
Every single time
I moved it up a bit.
Hope it's the right one.
We'll see how it goes here.
Come on go!
Go!
Come on.
Let's go, boys.
Here come some weights.
Oh, my God.
What the hell is that about?
I can see the glow.
Yeah, it’s a shark
He gone just came off.
Oh, well,
that was a little bit disappointing, huh?
Get back to the drift
and hopefully hook back up.
Let's get him.
Let’s get him.
Lets get him buddy.
We are on fuego right now.
Let's go,
Want me to go?
Go to port go to port.
Forward, forward.
Oh there he is
no, no, hold on.
Tie breaks.
Come up right here.
Nail him!